this week President Trump signed a law
extending a pilot program on health care
for veterans it allows some vets covered
by the VA to receive treatment through
private providers the program was
enacted following the 2014 scandal at
the VA that found some vets waiting
weeks even months to receive medical
treatment while the law received
bipartisan support some see it as a step
towards privatizing the VA here to talk
about that and other issues affecting
veterans were pleased to be joined by
the Secretary of Veterans affair dr.
David Shulkin mr. secretary thanks and
welcome to the program good morning
let's first talk about the news of the
week and how that might affect veterans
we're hearing from the White House that
they're gonna take another stab at
repealing the Affordable Care Act a
study that came out this week shows that
the uninsured rates of veterans under
the age of 65 fell 40% between 2013 and
2015 largely because of the ACA what is
the implication as far as veterans
concerned are concerned if the ACA is
repealed well first of all I think we're
gonna have to take a hard look and see
exactly what the legislation says
they're hard at work right now seeing if
they can come up with something that
will pass but no matter what happens the
VA will be there as a healthcare system
for veterans and so if more veterans
need to come to the VA we will be
prepared to do that are you willing to
take those beliefs about veteran's
health care to the White House and
express them to the president the
president shares my commitment that we
are going to be there for veterans
veterans have to get the services that
we owe them as a country and that's the
job that the VA has you're the you're a
holdover from the Obama White House what
change if any are you seeing with this
administration so far well what I'm
seeing is really a bipartisan commitment
to making sure that we fix the issues
that have been plaguing the VA for years
and what I'm seeing is just a consistent
desire to move quickly and to make some
hard decisions to fix the VA
mr. secretary during your confirmation
you said that veteran's health care
would not be privatized and yet this
week the President signed a bill that
would allow some veterans to seek
private medical care how do you square
those two things well in no way are we
seeking to privatize the VA what we said
is is that in order to get veterans the
care that they need we're going to have
to work closer
with the private sector and so we're
looking for a system that takes the best
of what VA has to offer which is
tremendous services for veterans but
also supplement it with what the VA is
not doing and use the private sector so
it's an integrated approach to care
there's a possibility of a government
shutdown ahead how might that affect the
VA
well the VA is in a fortunate situation
in that we have what's called an
advanced appropriation so we get our
money a year ahead of time because I
think Congress understands that the VA
can't shut down that we are there for
the safety of our veterans so there's a
risk to veterans here there's no risk to
veterans well there's gonna be a press
conference with the president on
Thursday we're expecting an announcement
what what might we hear you'll be there
well we're gonna be talking about the
tremendous progress that we're making
and how we're honoring the commitment to
fix the VA and we're very excited to
share with the American people about all
the things that we're doing to honor the
commitment towards our veterans
secretary David Chilton thanks so much
for being thank you this morning